e
temporaire, récit lieu
d'interdire globalement. Après
on verra.
- Allons retrouver tout de suite
Valérie Plante et Marc Demers
maire de Laval. Bonsoir à vous
double
- Bonsoir Madame Drolet.
- Mme Plante commence avec vous,
vous avez dit : j'ai vu des
engagements clairs et le flou on
n'en veut pas. Les avez-vous
trouvés clair aujourd'hui?
- Écoutez, je vous dirai
certains niveaux, oui, mais en
même temps, sans même temps ce
que l'on souhaite. Il va souvent
y avoir des joutes entre : est-
ce que c'est des hommes d'assaut
des armes . Sur ce qu'on Andison
au territoire que ça se passe en
avant la détresse et
l'augmentation de la voyance. Ce
qu'on veut c'est que les hommes
de poing et d'assaut soit
prohibé et réglementé pour que
ça ne soit pas banale et qu'on
puisse vraiment contrer de façon
efficace la criminalité et les
groupes criminels et qui utilise
des armes à feu. Et ça ça veut
dire prohiber et mieux contrôler
les frontières et dévastèrent
massivement pour les protéger.
- Monsieur Demers c'est un
ancien policier aussi, ils en
vous savaient ce que c'est les
dégâts que ça cause. Ça fait des
ravages aussi dans votre ville.
Pourquoi c'est important pour
vous que les chefs de parti
légifèrent mais différemment
c'est-à-dire sont beaucoup plus
stricts avec les armes :.?
- Les hommes d'assaut devraient
être interdites, les armes das
:. Contrôler beaucoup mieux.
Elle pourrait être disponible
seulement dans des clubs de tir
où l'environnement est contrôlé.
Mais ça prend une législation
claire sinon nos services de
police ne peuvent pas
intervenir.
Oui il y a des enjeux d'argent,
nous on a résidé le 28 et le 25
août on a mis un point de milieu
million pour venir en aide avec
le maire suppléant, Monsieur
Stéphane Boyer le directeur de
la service de la police mais ce
n'est pas suffisant. S'on ne
contrôle pas nos frontières, les
gens vont entrer et on n'y
pourra rien. Je vous dirai si je
veux faire une analogie, les
armes à feu sont un peu le virus
par lequel la violence propage
et on sait jusqu'à quel point la
maquerelle faut contrôler les
choses.
- Monsieur Trudeau vous dit
qu'il a de l'argent et Kévin ont
juste le demandé mais c'est
parce que vous voulez.
- Bien non parce qu'en fait
j'aime faire comprendre cette
logique ou tout d'un coup, ce
serait une gestion par
territoire alors qu'on
s'étreignit que la criminalité
et les armes sont en pleine
circulation d'une ville à
l'autre.
Mais également d'une province à
l'autre et c'est là que pour moi
je m'explique mal ses
difficultés qu'ont les chefs
politiques à vraiment prendre un
engagement disant : ce qui va
les chasser, ça va. Vous avez
droit de faire, mais que le code
criminel soit adapté
et qu'on protège nos frontières
et oui, de l'argent sur la
prévention absolument, mais ce
qu'il faut envoyer ce message
clair comme quoi qu'au Canada ça
ne sera jamais comme aux États-
Unis. On ne va pas banaliser
cette violence, on va faire une
priorité
et c'est là pour moi ou sa
manche manque encore de danse
que les différents chefs nous
disent.
Encore une fois ne perd pas des
hommes : mais des armes
d'assaut.
- Monsieur Demers comment vous
la comprenez cette hésitation
des chefs de parti? On a peur du
lobby des hommes? On a peur de
l'association des chaleurs des
chasseurs? Qu'on donne un mot
d'ordre propreté pour nous?
Qu'est-ce qui empêche les chefs
de parti de ne pas franchir le
pas que vous leur demandez
trancher?
- Aucune raison je ne vois pour
ça. Vous avez probablement
toujours; le point sensible,
c'est de perdre des votes. Mais
ça prend le courage politique
c'est la sécurité des citoyens
qui est en jeu présentement.
Évidemment on parle souvent de
meurtre, mais les armes causent
beaucoup d'autres problèmes que
juste les meurtres, uniquement
les moeurs. Les agressions
sexuelles, les enlèvements, les
séquestrations, énormément de
crimes et n'importe quel
policier qui a oeuvré dans ce
domaine va vous le dire.
On a besoin de contrôler les
contrôles vont donner des
renseignements et permet des
suivis sur les gens. Et les
armes. Le but c'est de prévenir
ces situations.
- Est-ce qu'il y a un enjeu de
région contre les villes?
- Je ne passe pas, il y a une
certaine désinformation.
De vouloir mettre des chasseurs
en opposition avec les
problématiques, avec la montée
de la violence. Je pense que
c'est un des problèmes majeurs.
Tout alors la question vous
posait, je reste un élément,
tant ils sont temps qu'on ne va
pas s'attaquer à la racine du
problème, présentement les
policiers qui nous disent : à
chaque fois qu'on enlève une
arme
il y en a 10 nouvelles clientes.
Qui circulent. C'est comme un
coup d'épée dans l'eau.
Un moment donné il y a une
station une augmentation de 80 %
disant du nombre de liquidations
des armes à feu, c'est un fait.
Ce sont des données réelles il
faut pour se poser des questions
dans quelle société on peut
vivre.
Et je veux m'attaquer racine du
problème et non pas juste donner
de l'argent pour gérer le
territoire.
Les impacts négatifs dont
Monsieur Demers parlait.
- Monsieur Demers quand on
enterre Monsieur Erin O'Toole,
il va durer avec le crime et
s'attaquer aux gang de rue. Si
vous aviez Erin O'Toole devant
vous auriez envie de dire quoi?
- Écoutez, j'ai couvert
plusieurs scènes de décès,
certaines c'étaient le crime
d'autres c'était des suicides et
donc des accidents. Ils sont
aussi difficiles à gérer l'une
que l'autre. Je l'impression que
si les décideurs avaient ou été
confronté à de telles situations
innées et trépas à augmenter le
contrôle sur les armes à feu.
- Il reste un an que l'autre
option que Monsieur Trudeau met
sur la table, c'est de dire :
écoutez l'argent peut être géré
par la ville et par province.
Des gens viennent monter d'un
étage.
Mme Plante est-ce que ce début
de solution?
- Écoutait, moi aujourd'hui le
message que je passe c'est quand
Satan a plus
on s'attend du courage politique
et j'aimerais rappeler que la
raison pour laquelle on ne
voulait pas les vices qu'utilise
du contrôle des armes à feu,
c'est que les hommes n'ont pas
de frontières. À Montréal sont
les contrôles, mais que dans une
autre ville pour différentes
raisons ce n'est pas les mêmes
règles, ce n'est pas les mêmes
effectifs encore les mêmes
ressources, qu'est-ce qui va se
passer un hiver niveau
interprovincial? Voici ma
préoccupation c'est toujours la
même idée d'en revenir à la
racine du problème et de bannir
les hommes : les hommes d'assaut
et ça n'a presque jamais les
chasseurs de chasse chasser mais
ça va empêcher un premier délit
polytechnique prochain dans